[Music]
you put your shoes in this boot your bag
in that you put your personal items in a
tiny plastic bag I do the boogie boogie
and I touch it all around that's what
it's all about
hi I'm from the TSA the only government
agency that can check the status of both
your flight and suppository not familiar
with TSA security regulations well come
on put your arms like this you spread
your legs like that we send the pictures
back and maybe through the internet we
do the pokey pokey and we touch all
around that's what it's all about and
while we check out pictures of your
naked body we're also checking out the
contents of your bag Oh looks like
somebody's about to wage a jihad against
plaque please put your shoes in this
please go take off your shoes it seems
we can't communicate with anything
that's wearing shoes we do the pony
pokey and we touch it all around that's
what it's all about and if you're not
comfortable with the government taking
naked pictures of your body no problem
here's how you opt out you put your
rides in that your dignity in this
aerobic a man down because you don't
want the negatives I do the pokey pokey
and a touch all around that's what it's
all about and here at GSA we're always
employing the latest in terrorist
profiling procedures like these who
touch a kid like that we grope your kid
like this we touch your mum and down
because they might be Tamara
we do the pony pokey cousin somehow are
allowed that's what it's all the bad
[Music]
you
[Music]
you